تخيل أنك تجيب على باب منزلك
وتطاردك الشرطة بالبيتزا الخاصة بك،
يا إلهي، يا إلهي،
ولكن هذا ما فعله رجل توصيل البيتزا
الذي أثار الرهبة، ولم
يسقط حتى شرطة بيتزا بروكهافن بنسلفانيا،
أوه، نحن نطارد سيارة مسروقة مشتبه بها
عندما خرج الأمر عن السيطرة،
تولى رجل توصيل البيتزا السيطرة عن طريق
تعثر أحد اثنين من المشتبه بهم الهاربين،
قرر تايلر موريل البالغ من العمر 17 عامًا من مطعم Coco's Pizza
وضع قدمه على الأرض وكأنني لا أستطيع فعل
أي شيء بيدي لأنني  أنا
أحمل البيتزا لذا فقد أخرجت ساقي،
أصيب تايلر بكدمة منها لكنه
كان مملوءًا بصنع البيبروني
مع الثناء، أقوم بتوصيل البيتزا والأشرار،
نعم، لقد سئمت جدًا من رؤية
جريمة كهذه تحدث بصراحة، لقد كنت كذلك  فقط على
استعداد للتقدم وإذا احتاجوا إلى
يد كنت هناك أو قدمًا
مهما
حصل المشتبه به على علاج فتى الكاراتيه
يمسح ساقه بلا رحمة،
لم تكن هذه هي المرة الأولى التي
يمنح فيها المارة رجال الشرطة ساقًا لمحارب
مخضرم مع  ظهر سيء وعصا أعاقت عرضًا
مشتبهًا به مسلحًا
تطارده الشرطة في أوهايو، لقد اتخذت ساقي
الخيار بالنسبة لي، شكرت شرطة بروكهافن
عامل البيتزا، إذا كنت مهتمًا
بوظيفة، فنحن نبحث دائمًا عن
الأشخاص الطيبين الذين طلبوا البيتزا التي قدمها
مراجعة رائعة 10 من أصل 10 عمليات توصيل
لم يقم تايلر بتوصيل البيتزا الجاهزة فحسب، بل
قام بتوصيل الطلبات الخارجية في
نيويورك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]